stay tuned to the end of this video
because it is time once again for the
nerdfighteria senses good morning john
it's the last reunion video
it's question tuesday we answer a real
question from real nerdfighters we're
gonna get right to it it's the youtube
edition yeah who was your favorite og
youtuber back in the real early days um
community channel natalie train
my 2006 favorite was probably lonely
girl 15. yeah my 2006 favorite probably
like
the wine cone oh i loved the wine cone
and zay frank of course when did you
realize this was gonna be your job it's
still not my job i don't get paid to do
this so
uh now careers on youtube tend to be
very short like hank and i've been on
youtube for 15 years now and so we've
seen how yeah really really good careers
can not last very long and the people
who stick around tend to be people who
reinvent themselves a lot
which we don't do and us sam asks what
do you think are the best and worst uh
site functionality changes youtube has
made over its existence well in 2007 the
site didn't work and people forget about
this but like the site works now yeah
that's very impressive player is very
good players people forget how good the
player is so good there are a lot of
secret hotkeys yeah that's my favorite
ux thing where like yeah if you know you
can do a bunch of things you can go back
a frame or you can go back 10 seconds
frames in terms of my least favorite
feature
i think it was better yeah when it was a
five-star system
wow because then they went to likes and
dislikes and now they got rid of
dislikes i think five stars was the best
yeah but i'm old so of course i think
that and also i wrote right about the
five star scale was there any time jason
asks uh during brotherhood 2.0 that you
wanted to stop
yes like in march where
it still felt like a really long project
but the hard part for me is always
imagining the future that gets really
overwhelming right in the present it was
always fun um jeremiah asks when is the
next x jokes in four minutes coming
that's what the first minute of dear
uncle john is for yes that's where i do
that now jessica asks who got the play
button for vlogbrothers or do you take
turns and i do not know the answer i
don't know where it is
i just look at the background to see if
i have it i don't think i do i think
it's on the wall it complexly okay i
remember i was on a plane when we hit 1
million subscribers and i remember the
feeling
it was incredible
and now i never think about it who is
your oldest youtuber friend hank ah that
yes i feel like hank and i are really
lucky that we have each other because if
we didn't i wouldn't have a peer and now
i have a colleague it's very hard to do
this on your own who understands what
it's like
from the inside uh robin says i miss
video responses do you miss video
responses i miss them now way more than
i missed them when they actually got rid
of them because i feel like they would
do better now some people forget this
but like video responses were widely
misused yeah it's really uh easy to
forget how much we know about those days
of youtube thanks for chatting about it
with me a little bit it's been fun
it's been fun
mostly
i had a good time i thought you meant
the entire 15 years oh no no i meant the
last 12 minutes
thank you to everybody who's been
through even a little bit of it with us
and john
i'll see you
on tuesday
yeah on my computer screen yeah i know
it's sand i have to poo so the
nerdfighteria census is a yearly or in
this case because some things came up a
bi-yearly survey that helps us know what
we should be thinking about and focusing
on and how we should be interested in
this community and it's super valuable
for everything that we do together so
please follow the link in the
description to fill out the census it's
one of my favorite projects of the year
and i'm so so so looking forward to
hearing everyone's thoughts thank you
again link in the doobly-doo